hello in this video I'll talk about the
Cori cycle which is a metabolic pathway
which operates under low oxygen
conditions in the liver and muscle and
this ensures that the excess lactate is
produced during the anaerobic glycolysis
is converted to glucose in the liver and
this kind of pathway ensures that excess
lactic acid does not build up in our
body and it also reduces chance of
lactic acidosis which is pretty
dangerous and can change the blood pH
the Cori cycle was discovered by the
Cori couple Carl Cory and Gertie curry
both of them discovered and got nobel
prize for these pathway and this pathway
has a long implication in terms of
diabetes so let's try to understand the
context let's say we are performing
heavy training or power exercise in the
gym now in terms of resistance exercise
we perform our exercise in high
reputation right so in a very short
period of time our muscle need a hell
lot of oxygen from the blood but the
blood flow is not sufficient enough to
provide that amount of oxygen to our
muscle in a very short span of time
also our muscles need to contract it
needs ATP and muscle need particular
pathway to generate that ATP so in this
situation there is a hypoxic condition
taking place in the muscle and in low
oxygen condition the muscle would
undergo anaerobic glycolysis why is so
so we know that glucose can be converted
to pyruvate in the process of glycolysis
and ATP can be generated further that
pyruvate can enter the mitochondria
become as
they'll coil and ultimately give rise to
krebs cycle
eventually the products of krebs cycle
fadh2 nadh these things can be channeled
into electron transport chain and they
can work like electron donors right but
the terminal electron acceptor is oxygen
so under aerobic condition oxygen works
like an electron acceptor and completes
electron transport chain
coupled with the electron transport
chain ATP is generated but in an aerobic
situation none of these can take place
because etc' won't be functional under
this situation so what is the alternate
muscle has to depend more and more on
glycolysis to generate ATP now in this
situation in this kind of anaerobic
situation muscle prefers to convert
pyruvate into lactic acid or lactate and
this is called lactic acid fermentation
now inside the muscle you must be
thinking that pyruvate is converted to
lactate and it might be harmful because
lactate can change the blood pH lactate
can cause lactic acidosis and all of
these things and it takes place by
lactate dehydrogenase enzyme okay but
one important thing is generated as a
by-product in this conversion process
that is NADH get converted into nad
now this nad is very important to fuel
glycolysis if you don't have enough
supply of nad plus then glycolysis would
also stop and in anaerobic situation
where etc' is not functional in this
situation if glycolysis stopped then
there would be a failure in terms of
contracting the muscle right so in this
situation it is necessary to frame the
glycolic glycolic pathway with nad and
that is generated as a by-product
pyruvate is converted to lactate and
that's a very important significance of
this pathway now lactate is generated so
lactate would be then up taken by the
liver so let's see what happens but this
procedure ensures that during glycolysis
must during glycolysis the nad is not a
limiting factor so in AD the glycolytic
pathway should not run out during this
anaerobic situation now the question is
how the body ensures that lactate do not
reach a toxic level so this is very
important for the body as well because
body need energy as well but at the same
time body cannot tolerate a very high
level of lactate so liver come into the
picture so this is the muscle in the
muscle we saw that glucose is getting
converted into pyruvate in a glycolytic
pathway and this is anaerobic glycolysis
and ATP is generated two molecules of
ATP is generated and in this process
NADH was produced
now pyruvate gets converted into lactate
the NADH is now converted to nad and
that nad can refuel the glycolysis
itself in the muscle and it can give a
steady supply of ATP under anaerobic
condition but the problem was the
lactate now lactate moves into the liver
in the liver the lactate builds up now
lactate can be converted to pyruvate
inside the liver the pyruvate is not
toxic with this pyruvate can be utilised
the liver utilized by the liver to make
glucose by the process known as new
glucose analysis in this process
pyruvate gets converted to glucose and
glucose gets further transported into
muscle and any other place of the body
to fill that organ with energy so
overall what we learn from the quarry
cycle is that Cori cycle prevents the
lactate build-up in our body and saves
our body from lactic acid toxicity but
at the same time it
in this process nad is produced and this
nad fills up the glycolysis that is
taking place under anaerobic condition
such that under anaerobic condition body
does not run out of ATP specially our
muscles does not run out of ATP and no
failure of muscle contraction should
occur so this is a safeguard mechanism
as well but also chorus ichael ensures
in lactate level is regulated inside our
body so these are the two most important
implications of the Curie cycle so I
hope you enjoyed this video if you liked
this video give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
and do let me know in the comment how do
you like my videos thanks guys